cardi b went all out for her first red
carpet appearance since giving birth and
she slayed the whole damn thing oh yes
honey the wap rapper dressed to the
nines to attend the mugler exhibition in
paris on tuesday big things on the way
big bangs the mom of two rocked this
body-hugging red sequin gown with a
crystal encrusted bustier by mugler a
towering feather cape with a velvet
train matching sequin red gloves a
statement necklace and earrings cardi
went blonde for the event and sported
bejeweled eyebrows and a nude lip
but cardi didn't just wow in one look
she wowed in two changing into this
black leather corset with feather
trimming and matching gloves and a black
leotard with a sheer skirt
cardi later thanked mugler on instagram
for including her writing in part quote
truly one of my favorite creative minds
in the world i'm mind blown looking at
your collections from over the years a
true genius
of course cardi and offset welcomed
their second child a baby boy on
september 4th the two have yet to reveal
their new bundle of joy's name but the
rappers are already parents to
three-year-old daughter culture she's so
cute i love her offset is also a dad to
daughter kalea and sons cody and jordan
from previous relationships
barbecue sauce barbecue mead grilled
meat is a real fat craving
baby cardi first announced she was
expecting baby number two at the 2021
bet awards in june
and after that gave fans an inside look
at her pregnancy
how to see your stinky butt stinky butt
how to see your stinky butt
it's so sleepy
oh baby sleeping she even showed off her
sweet baby bump in the music video for
her collab with lizzo rumors
nobody listen they buying them streams
they even posted on blogs
in a statement the couple announced the
arrival of their little one quote we are
so overjoyed to finally meet our son he
is already loved so much by family and
friends and we can't wait to introduce
him to his other siblings
[Music]